小編跟我說
有人盜用我的照片
甚至用AI仿我的聲音
說我在賣牙粉
講得跟我一模一樣
這些通通都是假的
我從來沒有賣過
牙粉
固齒散
皮膚膏藥
足貼
茯苓膏等等
就是因為他產品太差
成份有問題
才會盜用名人的照片名字
假借別人的人氣
來賣產品
這不是詐騙
那叫什麼呢
你千萬不要買
我馬上教你
一款有效的
固齒配方
我都分享給我的朋友團隊
他們用了很多年
能解決你的牙齒問題
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要跟你分享
1.改變3件事 逆轉牙齦萎縮
2.牙齦萎縮 牙齒鬆？2器官恐出問題
3.牙齒少於這數量 失智風險高1.9倍
4.逆轉牙鬆口臭 固齒神方救牙根
5.椰子油漱口法 抗菌強化牙齦
改變這3件事 逆轉牙齦萎縮
有一件很離譜的事
有一個人
她吃了三顆牛軋糖
竟然要花掉一萬塊
那個人
是來自杜拜的有錢人
還是牛軋糖是金子做的
他吃了牛軋糖
吃到第三顆的時候聽到
咔一聲
牙齒斷了半根
花了一萬塊錢做假牙
十個一千塊錢就飛走了
牙齒斷掉
最常見的真兇
就是牙齦萎縮了
牙齦一旦萎縮
就很難恢復
注意這三件事
讓你的牙齦萎縮得更快
忽略牙周病
刷牙太用力
吃軟不吃硬
第一有牙周病要治療
別讓細菌從牙齦進入
牙周病它是牙齦殺手
細菌會從牙齦進入血液
然後還會悄悄的增加
中風
心臟病
糖尿病
等等的風險
當你發現
刷牙的時候
會流血
牙齦紅腫
這就是初期的警訊
不要拖趕快處理
第二件事刷牙不要太用力
大力橫刷
讓牙齦退縮
牙根外露
來推薦你一個
很多牙醫都推崇的刷牙法
貝氏刷牙法
預防蛀牙
和牙周病
貝式刷牙法怎麼刷
記得刷毛要選
軟毛的牙刷
才能夠清潔
牙齦溝
避免傷害牙齦
牙刷拿45度
貼合牙齦和
牙齒交界的地方
像這樣轉圈圈這樣刷
不要這樣橫刷
正確刷牙刷兩分鐘
內側外側
咬合面都要刷到
才是真正的刷乾淨
第三個 軟硬都得要吃
吃軟不吃硬
小心牙齦退化更快
你家的阿公阿嬤
是不是也會這樣
吃麵
吃粥
燉湯
喝得好開心
稍微咬硬一點的東西就說
哎呀我咬不動啦
咬不動不想吃了
這就叫做吃軟不吃硬
我再說一次
你長期吃太軟的食物
牙齒的咀嚼力
越來越差
牙齦就會跟著退化了
你有咀嚼力不足的問題嗎
建議你一週吃三次
軟硬適中的食物
蘋果
水梨
芹菜
地瓜
馬鈴薯
堅果
嘿 給它吃起來
這些有點硬度的食物
能訓練你的咀嚼力
刺激牙周組織
延緩牙齦的萎縮
牙齦萎縮牙齒鬆 2器官可能出問題
牙齦出狀況
不單純是牙齒的問題
根本的原因
還是你的腎
脾胃出問題囉
清朝的名醫葉天士他說
齒為腎之餘
齦為胃之絡
牙齒要靠腎氣來滋養
牙齦跟脾胃的火氣
也有關係
這兩種體質
牙齦容易出狀況
一是腎虛
二是脾胃火太旺
腎虛的人會怎麼樣
牙齒鬆鬆的痠痠的
咬個花生都會痛痛的
黑色食物把它吃起來
黑色食物
補腎氣
黑豆
黑芝麻
核桃等等
都試試看
一個很重要的概念
該躺平的時候就得躺平
我說的躺平
不是年輕人說的那種躺平喔
是說你要早一點去睡
第二個
脾胃火旺的人
牙齦常常紅腫
會痛
還會流血
嘴巴一張開
呃 那個味道可難聞了
再加上容易便秘
這就是火氣攻上來了
兩個退火妙招告訴你
喜歡喝茶的人就喝一杯
菊花決明子茶
清肝明目
你是愛喝甜湯的人
去巷口 超商
買一碗綠豆湯
來清熱解毒
兩種食物不要吃
炸的辣的食物
禁止進口
為什麼啊
先讓脾胃休息休息
牙齦才不會
天天給你鬧脾氣
喜歡這一集的朋友
還沒訂閱的人
趕快訂閱起來
我會提供給你
各種省錢又有效的健康妙招
牙齒少於這數量 失智風險高1.9倍
別小看缺了一顆牙
牙齒一鬆
大腦可能跟著走鐘了啦
30歲那年
我牙痛去看醫生
醫生建議拔掉
拔完以後才知道
呵呵
惡夢開始囉
怎麼說
上面的牙沒了
下面的牙就沒了支撐
所以呢
就開始亂長往上亂飆
結果咬合失衡
接著又拔第二顆
從此咬東西就像輪胎打滑
一邊出力一邊空轉
到了我50多歲
牙齒越來越鬆
真是非常非常的慘喔
所以你才一直勸我們
缺牙一定要補啊
我不希望你跟我一樣
你以為只是少幾顆牙
不打緊
大錯特錯
根據日本神奈川齒科大學
助理教授山本龍生
發表在美國
身心醫學期刊的研究
他指出呢說
他們的研究團隊
針對4000多名
65歲以上的長者
追蹤4年
結果發現
牙齒少於20顆
又沒有裝假牙的人
失智風險
竟然比牙齒
超過20顆的
高出1.9倍
你沒看錯
是1.9倍
缺牙 牙齒鬆動
不只讓你咬不動
更可能連腦袋
也一起鬆動了
別因為怕花錢就不補牙
到頭來省下的
是補牙的錢
賠上的是
腦力
記憶力
甚至是未來的生活尊嚴
逆轉牙鬆口臭固齒神方救牙根
牙齒鬆
口臭
牙周病困擾的人
來
我給你分享一帖
流傳百年的
固齒神方
從3歲小孩
到80歲長輩都能用
每天刷一刷
穩固牙根
保固牙齦
改善牙周病
我先跟你說配方
你現在可以把它截圖下來
藥材有
青鹽5錢
石膏5錢
補骨脂4錢
花椒1錢半
白芷1錢半
薄荷1錢半
旱蓮草2錢半
防風2錢半
細辛1錢半
你請中藥行的老闆
把這些藥材磨成細粉
裝在瓶子裡
保存起來就可以了
牙粉打出來就是這個樣子
給你們看一看
它有兩個用法
早上起床呢
你用牙刷
沾一點牙粉到牙齒上
接著刷牙
就像我剛才講的
那種刷牙法
刷牙以後
不要馬上漱口
讓牙粉停留在
牙齒上一分鐘
先洗臉把臉洗好了之後
再用清水來漱口
第二種
把牙粉塗在牙齦上
停留3到5分鐘
最後用清水漱口
就塗的就好
我有在用牙粉
效果真的很不錯耶
我還買回去
給我爸媽使用
很好
我跟你說一個故事
清朝那個名醫
叫做陳修園的
在他的 醫書72種
裡面記載
說有一個40歲的男人
掉了三顆牙
遇到一位相國姓盧
盧相國的弟弟
他傳授這帖牙粉
給了陳修園
陳修園用了牙粉
一陣子之後
不只是讓鬆動的牙齒
變得更牢固
連牙病竟然都痊癒了
冬天吃火鍋
牙縫腫痛
用這個粉末一擦
就立刻消腫
如果小孩三四歲的時候開始用
持續不斷
牙齒到老了都不會掉
哈哈
一輩子都不用
受牙痛的煩惱
太厲害了吧
媽媽怎麼幫
小孩用這個方子呢
當媽媽的
你可以拿紗布
沾一點牙粉
擦在牙齒表面上
尤其是三歲以上的小朋友
這個時候牙齒
正在生長
牙齦成型的黃金期
用這個牙粉
讓牙齒更乾淨
更整齊
記得把這麼好的神方
分享給家人朋友
讓牙齒越來越健康
椰子油漱口法
抗菌加固牙齦一把罩
天天用漱口水
擔心化學成份太多嗎
試試油漱法
又叫做油拉法
油漱法呢
能夠減少牙菌斑
改善口臭
強化牙齦
油漱法是印度的
一種傳統保健法
用椰子油漱口
味道溫和
裡面的月桂酸
抗菌的效果滿不錯的
為什麼油能帶走細菌呢
油的質地
能夠吸附脂溶性的物質
在口腔裡面
跟唾液混合乳化
幫助帶走細菌和毒素
什麼時間做油漱法最好
早上起床的時候
你先喝一杯溫開水
然後開始做
1.拿一湯匙的椰子油
大概就是10～15cc
含在口裡面像漱口一樣
讓油流過牙齦與牙齒
還有牙齒間
2.漱口15到20分鐘
混合物會變成乳白色的
3.把油吐掉 不要吞下去
最好吐在垃圾桶
避免阻塞水管
4.接著照常刷牙漱口
就可以了
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同胡醫師推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦